bonjour mon père m'a toujours raconté des histoires
sur un monde caché où de braves
guerriers veillent sur nous et nous protègent n'est pas
si cool qu'il a toujours dit juste parce que
vous n'avez pas vu quelque chose ne veut pas dire que
ce n'est pas là
la tempête se termine je vois
Oh qu'est-ce qui se passe  sur la petite fille qui parle des
escargots en fait je suis une limace sans coquille sur
son bébé êtes-vous des gens super force nous
sommes l'homme feuille protecteurs de la
forêt tu es comme un fils
mon père avait raison
je vais détruire le quatrième mais je suis
Je ne vais le faire qu'une seule fois alors essaie de faire
attention avec nous maintenant
ouais j'ai fait le rêve le plus foiré
ils parlaient de limaces dans de tout petits
soldats et bonjour ah papa je suis là oh non je t'embrasse